bonjour à tous je suis ravi de vous
retrouver en direct sur figaro live
aujourd'hui vendredi 2 juillet 2021
c'est la journée mondiale des zones vni
l'occasion de faire un point sur ces
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
qui peuplent notre imaginaire collectif
et qui font ponctuellement la une des
médias alors réalité ou fantasme les
ovnis existe-t-il sommes-nous seuls dans
l'univers qu'en pensent les
scientifiques
et que disent les dernières enquêtes
réalisées sur le sujet ces phénomènes
sont ils pris au sérieux par les
gouvernements représentent ils un danger
pour les états et bien pour répondre à
toutes celles à toutes ces questions et
celle que vous vous posez évidemment
nous sommes avec un expert des ovni en
direction figaro live ou plutôt un
expert des pannes puisque c'est comme ça
qu'il faut désormais les nommer les
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
bonjour luc dini merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes ingénieur en
construction aéronautique membres de
l'association aéronautique et
astronautique de france 3 à f une des
rares sociétés savantes nationale et
vous êtes président de la commission
technique sigma 2 qui vient de publier
un rapport sur les ovnis l'ubs dit nick
comment ça s'étudie sérieusement les
eaux vont alors se situe 10 à partir
d'un certain nombre de documents de base
documentaire de base de données qui
relate des observations de phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés donc on sait
pas très bien ce que c'est au départ et
donc à partir de ces données
d'enregistrement et quand il y en a pas
ce que c'est c'est beaucoup plus précis
intéressant que les témoignages visuels
on on analyse le contenu par exemple si
vous avez vidéo infrarouge
si vous avez des éléments de la
situation aérienne radar de la zone où
était observé le phénomène
on croise tout cela on fait appel à
différents spécialistes ont fait une
reconstitution
voilà
maîtrise du timing et cetera et puis on
fait appel à nous à des experts des
rayonnements pour tenter de comprendre
ce qui a été observé et à partir de là
on fait le tri mais justement à propos
d'experts quel type d'experts
travaillent sur le sujet avec vous en
fait il ya une grande une grande
diversité il ya peu près entre 15 15 et
20 personnes qui contribuent avec des
expertises qui vont de la médecine des
rayonnements en passant par la détection
infrarouge le rayonnement infrarouge la
détection électromagnétique radar il ya
des pilotes pilote de chasse et un
astronaute qui est jean françois clervoy
vous avez également des spécialistes de
physique quantique des plasmas donc vous
voyez voilà spécialiste de l'observation
spécialiste des rayonnements médecine
etc et et chacun est capable d'apporter
sa sa contribution à l'analyse
si vous venez nous rejoindre en direct
sur figaro l'avait sur youtube nous
sommes aujourd'hui en direct pour vous
parler des ovnis avec un expert du sujet
luc dini il est avec nous en ce moment
pour répondre à toutes vos questions et
elles sont certainement nombreux ont
salué à ce propos moi band mohamed ben
et mita qui est en direct avec nous sur
le chat de youtube on espère de
nombreuses questions de votre part et
des commentaires à propos de précisions
à donner je disais dans cette
introduction
pourquoi vous préférez parler désormais
plutôt de panne ou de pan pea end plutôt
que de dire au bout du bout nique
alors c'est pas désormais en fait c'est
les films mode et les événements de ces
jours ci qu'ils mettent sur la scène
le mot ban est en réalité par effet
miroir dua paix américain pour un iphone
defied aérium phénoménal en fait cette
appellation existe depuis longtemps et
pour tout vous dire
le geipan qui existe depuis 1977
comporte dans son nom le les trois
lettres pan et vous voyez ce date de
1977 donc pour nous c'est pas très
récent et pour aller jusqu'au bout des
choses
au début de l'étude de ces phénomènes
dans les directives qui avait été donnée
en france et qui remonte aux années 50
on parlait à l'époque démoc pour
mystérieuse objets célestes en réalité
pense ça veut dire l'ensemble des
phénomènes qui songe qu'il est assez
étrange observé dans le ciel ou ailleurs
et qui nécessitent finalement des
enquêtes et des études
d'où la création du gip en france en 77
voilà j'ai pas on va préciser un qui
dépend du centre national d'études
spatiales le cnes et geipan qui veut
dire je groupe d'études et
d'informations des phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés comme vous
l'avez précisé je salue et je dis
bonjour sch 0 1 qui est en direct sur le
chat du figaro et que nous demandait ce
que le rapport détaillé de sigma 2 va
être difficile être diffusé en dehors de
l'association
on y reviendra sur ce rapport que vous
avez fait publier quelques jours est ce
que pour l'instant il est disponible sur
le site de l'association il est payant
pour le grand public ou en tout cas il
est accessible pour ceux qui y adhèrent
à l'association est ce qui va être
publié autrement que via votre votre
association
si vous voulez la démarche pour
l'adopter compte tenu des circonstances
et est très simple on a mis en ligne en
accès direct et libre la synthèse qui
fait 17 paquebot le synthèse du
pentagone ont fait 9
c'est open c'est libre on a un cas
d'étude très complet qui fait une
trentaine de pages sur un cas observés à
porto rico avec des analyses infrarouge
radars etc
c'est open c'est libre et pour ce qui
est du rapport complet qui fait 380
pages le principe est effectivement de
donner accès aux cotisants prête de
façon privilégiée
normalement on aurait dû attendre un
certain nombre de mois avant de le
mettre en ligne pour d autres personnes
est ce qu'on a décidé c'est de le rendre
accessible à tous alors il ya une
participation demande pas de prendre
cotisation à l'association
mais il ya une participation qui est une
participation minimale aux frais et qui
est de l'association vous avez beaucoup
de bénévoles en valeur la commission
sigma 2 on n'a aucune rémunération tout
ce qu'on fait gratuit bien entendu et
c'est pour étudier renseigné finalement
le public
donc s'il vous plaît si le rapport vous
intéresse ce qu'on espère et bien
télécharger le
inscrivez-vous à l'association ou bien
payer cette contribution minimale ça
nous aidera voit la version anglaise à
sortir le dîner pour que les internautes
qui nous écoutent en ce moment vous
connaissent un petit peu mieux
on aimerait savoir comment vous est
venue cette passion pour pour les ovnis
pour les pans alors passion pour les
ovnis c'est pas vraiment une passion
pour les ovnis en fait c'est un c'est un
hasard il se trouve que lors d'un départ
en vacances avec avec quelques amis nous
avons observé en direction d'orléans un
objet lumineux qui se déplaçaient une
tache lumineuse bon alors j'ai une
formation en aéronautique les rentrées
de météorites de satellites enfin bref
je connais simplement on a été très
étonné parce qu'on a observé je
connaissais l'existence du geipan et
donc à l' arrivée à destination
l'acompte la discussion a continué et
j'ai découvert totalement par hasard
l'existence du rapport cometa est un
rapport à ses célèbres sur le sujet et
mon étonnement a été grand en me rendant
compte en fait qu il est un fervent de
personnalités qui avaient planché sur le
sujet d'où un rapprochement auprès de la
3f à laquelle j'appartenais déjà avec la
commission sigma je savais que jean
françois clervoy qui appartenait donc
c'était un gage également et de sérieux
et et voilà et ce qui nous réunit avec
les autres experts au fond c'est la
passion de l'aéronautique et de l'espace
chacun dans nos disciplines pour essayer
de travailler sur un sujet qui est
compliqué pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe voilà en gros la motivation
c'est très clair je salue actarus sur
youtube bob lazare area51 mois benben
des limites à que j'ai salué tout à
l'heure et kenny g 23 excusez moi mais
leur pseudo est assez complexe chaque
fois ils n'ont ils ont des questions
pour nous que je vais vous relayer dans
quelques minutes
je voulais juste préciser que le
pentagone parce que certains nombres un
certain nombre d'internautes
ils font allusion le pentagone a rendu
public le 25 juin dernier un rapport
très attendu sur les ovni dont on peut
trouver d'ailleurs le contenu en
intégralité sur youtube sur sur internet
j'ai moi même
ces quelques pages du rapport officiel
américain ce rapport lui ont permis de
clore le débat sur l'existence des ovnis
une fois pour toutes
je pense qu il ne clôt pas le débat sur
l'existence des ovnis
il pose la question de l'existence de
phénomènes aérospatiaux non identifiés
dans le ciel américain ce qui est un
changement dans la politique de
communication américaine sur ce sujet
puisque depuis 1969
le dossier était clos en quelque sorte
donc là ils ont fait un certain nombre
d'observations qu'ils essayent de
comprendre et la question a été posée
d'ailleurs par le congrès américain au
pentagone pour constituer une commission
d enquête
donc en fait elle la logique vient de
s'enclencher
les enquêtes ont préliminaires ont été
faites et ce qui en ressort c'est
effectivement que healy à différents
types de phénomènes que certains ont
semblé très je dirais très bizarre et
qu' ils doivent continuer rassembler des
données allaient fiabiliser c'est en
gros ce que dit le rapport
que va-t-il se passer aux états unis
selon vous monsieur digne et après la
publication de ce rapport par le
pentagone
allons-nous avoir d'autres informations
ou est-ce que le sujet va retomber aux
oubliettes pour encore des années alors
bon c'est difficile de s'exprimer dont
nous n'avons pas de boule de cristal
les décisions qui seront prises par les
autorités américaines on ne les connaît
pas ce qui est certain c'est qu'il y à
un train depuis 2016 de mise à plat d'un
certain nombre d'informations
il faut savoir d'ailleurs que le
président obama avait donné des
autorisations de divulgation darche is
d'où d'ailleurs certaines archives de
l'agencé de renseignement américaine qui
ont été mises en ligne
il y à un courant de communication qui
s'est révélée fin 2017 avec en
particulier quelqu'un qui est luis
elizondo qui est un ancien du pentagone
qui a rejoint une firme privée etc et
qui est à l'origine de cette circulation
des fameuses vidéo infrarouge
alors maintenant il faut faire la part
des choses pour dire les choses très
très nettement les vidéo infrarouge qui
circulent les photos c'est très bien ça
ça met le doigt sur un sujet sur des
points d'interrogation sur des
observations du point de vue technique
et scientifique c'est totalement
inutilisable c'est pas que l'on met en
cause l'intérêt de ces informations
où je dirais leur origine c'est
simplement qu' on ne peut pas les
exploiter directement parce que une
image dans une caméra ça donne
quelques-uns informations mais ça ne
donne pas tout ça ne donne pas les
informations distance et c est ce que je
vous dis là c'est ce qu'ont expliqué
déjà trois en arrière et c'est la raison
pour laquelle on n'a jamais donné
d'interprétation de la vidéo infrarouge
ou des vidéos infrarouge de limite et
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
le pentagone lui même dans le rapport
qui a été rendu explique qu'il était
obligé de croiser les informations des
caméras avec d'autres données des deux
d'eads radar des mesures distance pour
essayer de lever l'ambiguïté sur ce qui
était observé donc en l'occurrence pour
l'instant on ne sait pas quelles seront
les données supplémentaires qui sont
révélés pour l'instant c'est un rapport
de situation qui est destiné aux
autorités politiques voilà sur un sujet
bien particulier et donc s'ils ne sont
pas des données scientifiques à propos
d'image l'udinese a justement vous
faites référence à certaines images
capturées par caméra infrarouge
j'aimerais qu'on regarde ensemble ces
images qui ont fait le tour du monde
l'an dernier le pentagone a déclassifié
des vidéos semblant montrer des ovnis il
s'agitait s'agissait de vidéos prises
par l'us navy la marine américaine qui
montrait des rencontres en plein vol
avec des airs aéronef non identifiée au
comportement inexpliqué je vous propose
qu'on ne regarde un extrait tout de
suite et on entend d'ailleurs les
pilotes qui échangent entre eux
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
luchini est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
de quoi il s'agit exactement et à quoi
assiste les pilotes à de la marine
américaine et qu'est-ce qui les surprend
exactement alors ce que l'on voit c'est
difficile à dire ce qui est certain
c'est que il s'agit de au moins de deux
prises de vues différentes autant que je
me souvienne il y en a trois au total
qui ont été diffusées sur internet
au début on voit donc un je dirais une
forme un objet qui est dans le champ de
la caméra
les quais vue sur un fond de nuages bon
premier diagnostic
l'image n'est pas de très bonne qualité
bon alors ça vient de la caméra où ça
vient je dirais des enregistrements qui
ont été faits c'est une première chose
l'objet est relativement stable dans le
champ d'accord donc il est suivi en
quelque sorte que peut-on dire d'autre
les commentaires des pilotes
c'est un sujet sur lequel on m'avait
interrogé dans une autre émission et sur
lequel j'ai entendu jacques greene s'est
exprimé récemment sur dans une émission
également les commentaires du pilote
sont un peu surprenant alors oui sont
vraiment sous l'effet de la surprise est
donc que libèrent leurs paroles et leurs
est tellement c'est fort possible
en même temps ça ressemble pas à des
commentaires qui sont des commentaires
de ce pilote en mission opérationnelle
qui sont des commentaires normalement
relativement laconique et factuel là on
est plutôt dans top gun avec tom cruise
points voilà alors ça c'est un peu
étonnant effectivement la deuxième vidéo
et les prises en contrebas on voit un
petit point blanc qui se déplace au
dessus de la mer
manifestement cette image et c'est
probablement prise plus récemment
on s'est posé la question entre les
vidéos 2004 celle là peut-être
appartient à une série de vidéos prises
en 2015 l'image est de meilleure qualité
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça si vous
voulez pour je dirais mais un peu il est
impossible de tirer la moindre
conclusion car on ne sait pas où est
l'avion
voyez vous avez dans le champ de la
caméra un sens d'indication dans la
sphère chilienne dont on reparlera
peut-être on avait ces informations là
mais on avait la trajectoire du porteur
donc on sait exactement où ils étaient
et à partir de là on peut commencer à
faire des hypothèses sur les distances
là on sait pas du tout on sait pas où
l'avion donc vous avez une tâche dans la
dans le dans la caméra très bien
impossible de dire ce que c'est et puis
la qualité de l'image ça bave
alors certains vous diront cette
extraordinaire il ya des plasmas c'est
ce que disaient les chiliens également
d'ailleurs dans la sphère cougar c'était
pas des plasmas dans ces cas précis
c'était des effets de pixellisation et
le fait que la tache lumineuse bavent en
fait sur les points adjacent donc voilà
voilà notre interprétation jour
d'aujourd'hui et franchement on peut pas
en dire plus a brièvement la phénomène
cougar on y reviendra tout à l'heure
j'aimerais juste vous posez la question
de sch 01 / sur le chat du figaro qui
demandent bien que les témoignages
d'américains proviennent de la marine
américaine de la navy il n'y a rien sur
la détection sous-marine avez vous déjà
étudié des cas d'ovni ou dépend pas de
sous marins pas du tout en fait c'est un
sujet qui est relativement récent pour
nous que l'on a
alors c'est un sujet qui apparaissait
dans les années 50 dans les les bases de
données américaines en tout cas qui
étaient signalées sous le nom de doha
nie donc pour objet aquatique enfin non
identifiés en gros voilà il semblerait
que les recherches russe des années 70
ont porté en particulier sur l'étude de
phénomènes
y compris au niveau pas dire maritime
aquatique
on n'en sait pas énormément de choses si
ce n'est qu'ils auraient fait des
enregistrements
voilà deux signaux de déplacement et
plus récemment donc effectivement dans
les éléments qui ont été communiqués par
les américains sur internet on a aperçu
cette fameuse vidéo prise d'un bateau
qui s'appelle l'omaha je crois bien
qu'ils à montrer l'esprit de se faire
avec un changement de milieu
ce qui est certain c'est que parmi les
caractéristiques étonnantes et qui ont
été répertoriés par un certain nombre de
services de recherche les les phénomènes
aérospatiaux non identifiés pour
certains d'entre eux sont caractérisés
par en quelque sorte que l'absence
d'interaction avec le milieu environnant
par exemple avec l'air et donc quand
vous avez affaire à des vitesses
supersoniques
vous avez une absence de bang
supersonique qui est classique
voilà donc on se pose des questions là
tu bien sûr on se pose aussi une
question évidemment c'est pourquoi les
américains ont-ils décidé
déclassifier ces vidéos maintenant
pourquoi ce rapport pourquoi le
renseignement américain dévoile-t-il au
grand public des observations qui l'ont
fait déjà depuis un certain nombre
d'années mais qui garde secrète à
écouter ça c'est difficile c'est
difficile à dire
dans notre rapport où on a fait un suivi
assez minutieux de la cascade
d'événements depuis 2000 fin 2017
nous ne sommes interrogés en fait début
dès 2018 en se posant de trois questions
au fond changement de communication
américaine
oui non y at il de nouvelles données y
aura-t-il des bases de données seront
elles accessibles oui non et puis à la
troisième question évidemment quelle est
la position américaine sur l'hypothèse
dit
l'hypothèse extraterrestre bon voilà
alors pourquoi ils communiquent
il ya plusieurs hypothèses et d'ailleurs
dans une émission avec alain juillet à
linge il ya des avis émis plusieurs
plusieurs hypothèses que l'on partage
d'ailleurs
soit vous avez effectivement une
tendance avec des gens et qui ont un
temps pressenti est alain juillet alain
juillet est un ancien responsable à
l'intelligence économique il a occupé
différentes fonctions y compris dans le
domaine du renseignement et c'est
aujourd'hui un consultant senior dans le
domaine du renseignement et de la
sécurité est donc bon c'est quelqu'un
qui connaît cet environnement et les
moyens de communication
donc soit en affaires un des courants un
peu contradictoire c'est-à-dire des gens
qui souhaite normaliser le sujet dépend
comme ça existe ailleurs en france est
un sujet qui est relativement
normalisées il ya un bureau enquêtes et
c'est aux états unis c'est pas le cas
d'accord donc il voulait pousser cette
tendance là et d'autres qui freine ou
alors c'est une politique de
communication qui est plus construite
certes ils se disent bon il est temps
effectivement d'informer le public sur
un ensemble de choses etc
et puis il ya la question de la sécurité
qui se posent en tout cas c'est la façon
dont il pose le sujet où les pilotes ou
observer des phénomènes
bon été eux face dans certains cas d
incident donc voilà d'une commission
denquête bon maintenant il n'y a rien de
dramatique non plus a contrario on
s'interroge pourquoi ils ont conservé
aussi longtemps ces informations en
gardant et en transmettant au public
c'était un secret et donc les fantasmes
sont eux sont nés auprès de la
population de cette espèce de chape de
plomb sur ces mystérieuses observations
qui ont entretenu voilà les théories les
plus folles sur la possibilité d'une
existence extraterrestre pourquoi ils
ont maintenu si longtemps pendant des
décennies ces secrets sur sur ses
observations
là aussi c'est un peu difficile à dire
mais ce que l'on peut dire quand même
c'est que l'histoire américaine dans ce
domaine couvre au moins je dirais une
première tranche de 20 ans au moins
en gros entre la fin des années 40 et
puis là la fin des années 60
l'us air force a mené des enquêtes et au
fond n'a pas vraiment conclut sur
l'origine des phénomènes leurs
caractéristiques
ils ont décidé de dire bon ben voilà de
toute façon on n'a pas de problème de
sécurité ce qui est factuel parce que
bon vous voyez enfin 69 qui s'est rien
passé d'extraordinaire entre nom et donc
ils ont pris une posture un petit peu de
déni c'est à dire ces phénomènes là
n'existe pas d'autres ont eu des
positions différentes les britanniques
ont travaillé là-dessus ont émis un
rapport qui est sorti en 2006 vous voyez
c'est déjà il ya quelques temps
bon la france à continuer de travailler
comme je voulais je voulais déjà dit
donc la position américaine position qui
était une position neutre est fermé
alors là aujourd'hui effectivement comme
il y à des observations qui sont faites
ils sont prêts à être obligé de
normaliser les choses et puis après vous
avez un climat international qui est
particulier que vous voyez donc la
question d'incursions dans l'espace
aérien a effectivement peut-être une
question sensible dont il
il faut un état de situation voilà c'est
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui que l'on
verra la suite si vous venez de nous
rejoindre en direct sur figaro live et
sur le tchat
et la chaîne figaro live sur youtube
merci de nous suivre en direct et
d'écouter les expertises et les
éclairages de l'udc dit ni notre expert
ce matin pour parler des ovnis dépens
ces phénomènes aérospatiaux inexpliquée
dont on entend beaucoup parler ces
derniers temps et qui nous interrogent
évidemment et vous interroge vous êtes
nombreux sur le chat de youtube à vous
poser c'est un certain nombre de
questions à faire des constats certains
parlent de peur évidemment alimenté par
les théories sur les des individus et
possiblement extra terrestre je lisais
il ya quelques minutes une réflexion de
christine couturier reconnaître
l'existence des ovnis ne serait ce pas
reconnaître qu'une civilisation serait
plus avancé technologiquement que les
terriens
mohamed benmouna qui est depuis le début
sur le chat du figaro sur youtube nous
dit la zone 51 aux etats-unis est-elle
un mythe ou une réalité merci nous dire
mais s'est dit ni est ce que vous pouvez
répondre à moi m d'ailleurs à ce sujet
ben je vais appeler un ami si vous
voulez bien je plaisante
bah écoutez la zone la zone 51 on en
entend beaucoup parler depuis très
longtemps d'ailleurs
il est certain qu'il y a des bureaux de
recherche et d'essai aux états unis sur
des programmes qui sont des programmes
confidentiel donc il est probable que
cette zone joue un rôle dans ces eaux là
dans ses programmes de recherche sur les
technologies avancées
qu'en dire de plus nous n'avons
absolument aucune opinion le fantasme du
rétro engineering sur des récupérations
d'objets de matériaux etc
c'est pas un sujet sur lequel on
travaille en réalité parce qu'on n'a
aucune information
donc on perd pas notre temps là dessus
voilà ce que je suis désolé c'est
peut-être un peu un peu light ce que je
réponds mais on essaye de s'exprimer sur
les choses que l'on que l'on connaît qui
sont interprétable d'équipement
scientifiquement laon on ne sait pas du
tout une autre question des mix m23
maximale en verre mais précise-t-il
était sur le point de nous quitter parce
qu'il a d'autres choses à faire mais
avant qu'il ne parte j'espère pouvoir
lui répondre il s'interrogeait mais
pourquoi c'est aussi tabou finalement si
on est
seul et qu'on sait où donc d'autres
planètes sont habitées ou même qu'on a
des extraterrestres sur terre pourquoi
ne pas en parler c'est pour pas effrayer
les gens ou quoi car en vrai je pense
que si tout le monde était au courant
on pourrait peut-être mieux prévenir
certains comportements en cas de
rencontre entre guillemets alors écoutez
sur ce point là je vais essayer de
répondre en prenant le contre-pied de la
question c'est à dire que à la question
y at il de la vie ailleurs
c'est un sujet qui était un non sujet
pour les scientifiques en tous les cas
bien semble donner tous les jours et il
n'y a pas besoin d'une journée sur les
ovnis on voit des communiqués sur des
recherches d'exoplanètes sur des
planètes candidates sur la recherche de
la vie dans l'univers qui porte le nom
scientifique qui s'appelle l'exobiologie
donc tout ça en réalité n'a rien à faire
avec les ovnis si ce n'est que au fond
dans le milieu scientifique on admet la
possibilité que étant donné l'immensité
de l'univers il puisse se faire que on
découvre des zones qui seraient propices
à certaines formes de vie voilà une fois
qu'on les lit formes de vie à quel
niveau
cantonné on connait l'âge de l'univers
connu un qui se compte en milliards
d'années à partir de là on peut imaginer
des tas de choses
voilà ça paraît quelque part logique
donc une fois qu'on a dit ça
toutes les hypothèses sont ouvertes et
manifestement la recherche de la vie
dans l'univers ne suscite pas
spécialement d'inquiétude mais au
contraire de la curiosité et de l' envie
de recherche
donc je pense qu'il faut ranger ce sujet
concernant les paons un petit peu dans
le même domaine
est ce qu'on voudrait d'ailleurs pour
conclure sur cette question c'est que le
monde scientifique
une attitude finalement de curiosité
similaires et pour caractériser analyser
les phénomènes qui se produisent plus
près et non pas je vous dirais les
considérer avec un une certaine distance
voire une certaine ironie dans certains
cas oui voilà la de la communauté
scientifique le dîner mais on a un
certain nombre de questions et j'allais
moi même vous vous la poser sur les
autres pays
engagé on va dire comme les etats-unis
ou la france dans la traque aux paons on
à l'internaute catherine vergnaud sur
you tube kids qui demande ne devrait-on
pas porter ce sujet comme une énigme qui
concerne toute l'humanité de la terre et
qui devrait susciter la recherche
scientifique mondiale en coopération
mondiale même c'est vrai on s'est un peu
mystérieux on parle toujours des états
unis on parle de la france mais est ce
que les autres pays s'intéressent à ce
sujet là est-ce qu'ils ont eux mêmes
observé des choses est ce qu il est
prévu une coopération mondiale sur le
sujet parce que vous parliez justement
mise en danger un de l'espace aérien
éventuellement alors mise en danger de
l'espace aérien
ça c'est une chute d'hier il l'inde est
l'une des questions plutôt qu'un constat
du côté américain au niveau de certaines
observations répétées et qui semble-t-il
bon ont posé un problème dans le
déroulement de certains exercices ou de
certains tests
bon vous savez moi quand je prends
l'avion je prends un bouquin j'écoute de
la musique je regarde le ciel
d'une part je traque pas les ovni en
regardant par le hublot et je me sens
parfaitement sèche donc voilà il faut je
dirais il faut il faut tranquilliser
tranquilliser le débat maintenant pour
ce qui est du partage des informations
entre différents pays le fait est que il
y a les bases de données encore une fois
je tiens à le dire parce que on entoure
le sujet de mystère oui il ya des
mystères où il ya des questions mais
s'agissant de la france en terme de base
de données je peux en citer au moins
deux lunes qui est celle du geipan je
vous assure si quelqu'un s'intéresse par
exemple à un cas qui est un call qui a
fait couler beaucoup d'encre du 5
novembre 1990 et bien vous allez sur le
site du geipan à toulouse il n'y a pas
besoin d'être inscrit quelque part et
vous allez avoir accès au dossier d'
enquête avec tous les pv de jambes
meurisse est très rare il ya eu des
témoignages de pilotes qui sont
consignés j'ai pu le vérifier de façon
extrêmement fidèle deuxième chose et ça
c'est plus récent vous avez également le
service historique de la défense avec le
fonds d'archivés de la gendarmerie qui a
fait l'objet d'annoncés sur internet il
ya quelques mois
et donc ces fonds d'archivés existait il
était d'ailleurs communiquer au géant
pour l'étude de cas anciens parce que
c'est sa porte sur la période
je crois en 1955 1975
mais ces données là sont accessibles il
faut s'inscrire comme lecteurs donc vous
voyez vous avez au moins à l'échelle
française a servi de base de données qui
sont accessibles et qui sont pas
interdites
deuxièmement au niveau international
puisque c'était la question posée c'est
un peu plus compliqué parce que bon il
ya des états chacun mène ses recherches
elle a ses bases de données
on peut en citer la suède par exemple a
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus depuis les
années 30
les britanniques ont sorti un rapport en
2006 tout en fermant d'ailleurs leur
bureau équivalent gérante qui étaient
chargés d'accueillir les témoignages
voyant française continue et est donc il
ya eu une tentative de résolution à
l'onu en 1978 je crois de mémoire pour
essayer de l'inciter à mettre en commun
les deux divorces
cette résolution n'a pas abouti
néanmoins il ya un mois on peut observer
que les autorisations de divulgation des
archives qui se sont fait séparément
dans différents pays pourraient répondre
d'une certaine façon à cette incitation
d'où le rapport britannique qui est un
rapport classifié qui a été déclassifié
en 2006 voilà donc il peut y avoir par
étapes
un certain nombre de pays qui se
décident effectivement à mettre sur la
table des archives voie suivre quelques
par l'exemple de la france en ayant une
agence spécialisée pour recueillir les
témoignages et communiquer ensuite les
informations sur les cas observés sur
les cas observés bien c'est vrai que
depuis le début de cette émission on
parle de phénomène inexpliqué observé
concrètement combat comment se
comportent ces objets ou phénomène
observé que font-ils qui n'entrent pas
ou qui ne respectent pas les lois
connues de la physique et ça rejoint la
question de marque sur le chat du figaro
qui nous dit vitesse d'accélération
changement
trajectoires brutale avez vous des
éléments probants alors il ya un certain
nombre d'éléments probants effectivement
dans certains cas et je vais prendre un
cas qui est deux cas à l'e3 si vous
voulez un cas qui est un cas anciens
britannique qui est très connue publié
dans les archives britanniques publiées
dans les archives américaines car lease
avait étudié ce cas là dans les années
les années 50 60
c'est le cas de les canifs c'est une
base aérienne de l'aef est en 1956 une
nuit du mois d'août je crois entre 21h
et 2h du matin des points lumineux sont
observés depuis le sol
depuis les avions points lumineux a
sorti d'ailleurs d'un écho radar point
unique ou groupés et se déplaçant en
s'arrêtant d'accord donc vitesse nul
puis accélération extrêmement rapides
changements de direction bon voilà un
des chasseurs britanniques est
intervenue a pris en chasse une forme
lumine 2 qui s'est retrouvé dans son
sillage voilà donc ya pas eu plus
d'accidents que ça mais ses
caractéristiques
parce que vous allez simultanément une
observation de phénomènes lumineux une
observation électromagnétique par un
radar des variations de vitesse
extrêmement rapide et ce cas qui est
emblématique qui a été repris d'ailleurs
dans la divulgation des archives de la
cia il ya quelques années est resté sans
explication deuxième cas qui est un cas
français où il n'ya pas de cinématiques
extraordinaire mais une observation qui
a été fait en 1994 par un équipage d'air
france sur un airbus qui était une
observation visuelle par l'équipage
d'une forme monde où j'ai trés cetera et
il y a eu un écho radar qui a été
détectée par ailleurs et qui ne
correspond pas qu'il n'est pas au même
endroit
sauf que sauf que l'apparition de cet
écho radar et sa disparition est
parfaitement synchrone de l'observation
visuelle ce qui pose question quand même
et on n'a pas d'explication là dessus ça
c'est dans les bases de données jugées
pendent quiconque s'intéresse au sujet
pour les consulter ce cas troisième cas
ça s'est passé à téhéran en 76
hélas il y a une mission menée par des
chasseurs avec des perturbations
électromagnétiques c'est à dire qu'ils
ont rapproché une forme plus vis d'eux
et quand ils en étaient très proches
leurs équipements de bord ont été
perturbés donc vous voyez voilà il ya
différents effets qui seront constatés
dans certains cas sur lesquels on se
pose des questions
actarus sur le chat figaro live sur
youtube vous pose cette question dans
votre rapport vous parlez de matériaux
aux propriétés remarquables et sensibles
aux ondes gravitationnelles
où avez vous lu cette info pouvez vous
nous en dire plus oui alors on peut en
dire plus
avec beaucoup de précaution qu'on a
prise d'ailleurs dans le rapport ces
informations là ne sont que la
réplication de rapports houde archive
november2008 il ya des livres qui ont
été écrits sur les travaux de recherche
russe et il y aurait eu des analyses de
matériaux et on s'est intéressé à ce
sujet là pourquoi parce que du côté
américain
l'équipe de la firme tsa dans le docteur
alpes et off qui a fait un certain
nombre d'exposés sur le fameux programme
de recherche à type américain a
mentionné l'existence soi-disant
d'échantillons de matériaux de
métamatériaux avec des propriétés
particulières
donc on a cité ses références là qui ne
sont pas des données de je dirais de
première ligne auquel on accéder ce
n'est jamais que par ouï dire ce qu'on a
lu par contre les recherches sur les
métamatériaux en fait les nanomatériaux
sont des matériaux multicouches avec des
structures extrêmement petit du niveau
du nanomètre ont des caractéristiques
particulières du point de vue je dirais
du guidage des ondes électromagnétiques
de l'absorption et ses îles cela on l'a
relaté parce que c'est totalement
scientifique
donc on a juxtaposé si vous voulez les
deux sujets maintenant on n'a pas de
connaissances particulières sur des
matériaux qui aurait été entre
guillemets retrouver c'est ce qui s'est
raconté enrichi c'est ce qui s'est
raconté aux états unis si certains
phénomènes restent inexpliquées un
d'autres au contraire ont été élucidés
vous citiez
un peu plus tôt le fameux mystère cougar
phénomène cougar est ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un petit peu de ce phénomène
qui a été décidé en définitive
oui oui bien sûr en fait l'histoire se
passe de mémoire en 2011
voilà un 11 novembre d'ailleurs un
hélicoptère cougar de la marine
chilienne
doté d'une caméra infra au jeu est en
train de faire un vol pour tester la
caméra bon caméra infrarouge est visible
et je tiens à préciser donc deux canaux
si vous voulez pour en faire des
observations
et puis tout d'un coup ils accrochent
une espèce de tache bizarre et donc se
pose la question mais qu'est ce que
c'est bon ils prennent contact avec le
contrôle aérien
on leur dit bon la visibilité est de 25
km 1 vous savez quand on se pose avec un
avion on donne des informations
visibilité et cetera bon très bien
donc ils se disent est ce que vous avez
un trafic aérien dans un rayon de 25 km
réponse du contrôle aérien non rien du
tout ah bon alors là ils se disent tiens
il ya un truc qu'on observe à la caméra
qu'on voit pas au radar mystère et donc
la faire part de là nous avons été
consultés on a on a on avait reçu les
organismes chilien l'équipe geipan de
mémoire fin 2014 ou en 2015 et nous
avions un accord et donc ils nous ont
consultés comme d'autres d'ailleurs en
nous demandant écouter voilà cette vidéo
ce truc là est invisible au radar vous
en pensez quoi
donc on a regardé la vidéo on a fait des
commentaires assez similaires à ceux que
je vous faisais tout à l'heure sur les
vidéos américaine en disant écoutez il
ya des effets de saturation et c'est
donc non on n'a pas vu de plasma sûr que
d'autres ou imaginées ont vu en tout les
cas on a dit écoutez pour l'instant on
peut pas conclure grand chose parce que
on n'a pas tellement d'informations sait
où l hélicoptère mais on n'a pas les
distances on on va pas pouvoir exploiter
petit et donc on s'est arrêté d'autres
points ont essayé de travailler là
dessus bref on découvre un article de
leslie keane dans le film tonnes post
faisant état d'une observation
extraordinaire et cetera bon très bien
et d'information radar disponibles donc
on a on a relancé les chiliens qui très
aimablement nous ont dit oui bien sûr on
a des données radar on a des données
météo
les envois et là on s'est mis au boulot
notamment avec un membre de l'équipe qui
est un ancien général de l'armée de
l'air un spécialiste des rayonnements
infrarouges et c est là en relativement
peu de temps en fait on a pu démystifier
le sujet
comment parce que justement à partir de
la situation radar à partir de la
consultation des archives de plan de vol
on a pu reconstituer le trafic aérien
dans la zone et il se trouve que la
limite de 25 km qui avaient été prises
en compte
n'était pas applicable et qu'on a
regardé plus loin et plus loin on a
découvert un avion qui était en
procédure de monthey qui avait quitté
l'aéroport de santiago qui était en
virage à 75 km ce qui correspond aux
première détection infrarouge et après
l'avion si vous voulez fini son virage
se présente par l'arrière est en montée
donc on le voit plein pot parce qu'on
voit les réacteurs par l'arrière ça
rayonne beaucoup et donc tout ça était
corrélé on a reconstitué les images
thermiques et on a renvoyé le dossier au
chignon disant écoutez il n'y a pas de
plasma il n'y a pas de nice est un
airbus a340 d'iberia alors certains ont
été déçus
bien entendu mais pour nous c'était eux
aussi intéressants les dénis quelques l
hypothèse sont aujourd'hui mises en
avant sur ces phénomènes inexpliqués
âges alizé en préparant cette émission
que certains pourraient s'expliquer par
la présence de drones ou d'oiseaux qui
créerait la confusion la confusion
auprès des systèmes radar des militaires
d'autres pourraient découler de tests
d'équipements ou de technologies
militaires effectuées par d'autres
puissances comme la chine ou la russie
ces hypothèses sont elle plausible selon
vous
tout est plausible s'agissant des drones
y en a de plus en plus tout le monde le
sait est donc évidemment les drones
peuvent parasiter en quelque sorte les
observations voilà dans notre rapport on
a consacré un chapitre aux drones et au
micro de rhodes en particulier à ceux
qui ont des caractéristiques
cinématiques extrême voilà pour savoir
quelles sont les limites de vitesse
d'accélération qu'on pourrait attendre
et c'est après vous avez dans pro type
d'engin vous avez évidemment les fameux
black programme d'avion furtif etc et on
peut pas exclure dans certains cas que
certaines observations soit en lien avec
de tels programmes
vous avez les tests de missiles vous
avez les fusées vous avez starlink avec
les micro satellites
donc tout ça fait parti d'un
environnement aéronautique et spatiale
qui justifie d'ailleurs au fond
l'intervention de spécialistes pour
débrouiller le paysage en quelque sorte
voilà donc oui c'est plausible dans
certains cas tout est plausible comme
vous le dites neuro invasion qui nous
avait communiqué sa question sur twitter
quand nous avons teasé hier pour vous
donner rendez-vous ce matin à 9 heures
et il vous demande l'udc dit ni quel est
le cas le plus étrange à votre
connaissance avec quelle probabilité lui
attribue riez vous une origine humaine
non humaine terrestre n'intéresse
naturel artificiel effectivement c'est
intéressant ça questions par rapport à
toutes les observations et toutes les
études que vous avez pas usé que vous
avez pu faire et n'a peut-être une qui
vous interpelle le plus écouté pour
éviter de me répéter parce que j'en ai
déjà cité des étranges enfin l'histoire
de léconi fait est très étrange et n'a
pas d'explication aujourd'hui j'ai envie
d'en citer d'autres qui sont d'origine
américaine et qui ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui
c'est les enregistrements de signaux
électromagnétiques qui ont été faits en
1957 et en 1959
du moins pour les cas qu'on connaît et
qui ont été publiés pour la c'est ce
qu'on appelle le krb 47
c'est un an via un avion
d'enregistrement électronique et qui
donc qui est aux états unis et qui
pendant plusieurs heures va suivre des
phénomènes lumineux donc sur plusieurs
centaines de miles et enregistrer des
signaux
donc dans les fréquences de l'ordre de
3,3 gigahertz signaux avec une certaine
modulation bon et on a un cas similaire
d'enregistrement donc à partir d'un b 52
c'est en 1959 c'est près d'une base
américaine près de la frontière du
canada qui va être suivi à une certaine
distance par un objet tout ça c'est dans
les dossiers publiés par l'us air force
ça se trouve également dans les archives
qui sont consultables c'est pas du tout
confidentielles et donc il y a eu les
enregistrements sur des fréquences
similaires donc nous avons essayé de
travailler sur ces sujets là voilà alors
de quoi s'agit-il d'un phénomène naturel
dont on peut se poser la question mais
ça paraît peu vraisemblable
même si on peut avoir des effets des
rayonnements électromagnétiques par des
phénomènes naturels
il faudra en savoir plus sur ces
enregistrements américains mais en tout
cas on a identifié des causes de
rayonnement électromagnétique et qui
pose question et qui sont étudiées dans
l'autre qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ceux qui restent malgré tout extrêmement
sceptique sur ce sujet puisque on est
toujours très étonné dont on parlait de
ces phénomènes via des témoignages de
témoins américain ça vient toujours des
états unis les ovnis ne sont vu que là
bas et puis s'ajoute à ça évidemment ce
qu'hollywood en a fait en récupérant ces
sujets là donc ça ajoute encore du
fantasme aux fantasmes c'est vrai qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ces petites à
écouter ce qu'on répond aux sceptiques
ou aux gens qui nous pose la question où
croyez-vous aux ovnis on répond c'est
pas une sujet un sujet de croyance
l'existence des phénomènes aérospatiaux
non identifiés est un sujet qui est un
sujet aux scientifiques avérées avec des
recherches sérieuses qui ont été menées
par un sombre deux pays
encore une fois l'actualité est rythmée
par la communication américaine par les
effets de médiatisation etc
mais l'histoire a commencé avant elle
c'est continuer après leur enquête et
elle se continue toujours
donc la réponse est plutôt de dire
plutôt que de dramatiser les choses de
les rendre extraordinaire vraiment où on
a besoin de l'aide encore une fois des
scientifiques
on a besoin de récolter des données
parce que vous voyez on est en train de
parler dépens mais dans ces phénomènes
là on a par exemple dans l'équipe le
directeur d'un lob laboratoire de
recherche sur la foudre qui s'intéresse
à des phénomènes de foot très
particulier qu'on appelle la foudre en
boule et vous avez les boules de foudre
qui peuvent se balader à quelques milli
mètres d'altitude
il ya des vitesses qui prend forme et
bien ils ont besoin de récolter des
données avec des caméras d'étudier la
trajectoire de ces choses là et cette
démarche là eh bien on n'est pas face à
l'impossibilité de la foudre en volume
alors que à une époque l'existence de
tels phénomènes et eni et dans le monde
scientifique
donc ces phénomènes sont avérés mais il
mérite encore des moyens de recueil de
données et bien les pans de façon
générale c'est la même chose on a besoin
de récolter des données
on a besoin de scientifiques qui les
analyse et de trouver des évolutions aux
théories voire de mettre le doigt dans
certains cas sur des choses qui sont
peut-être plus extraordinaire mais il
faut y travailler
j'aimerais vous faire par l'udinese
avant qu'on arrive au terme de ce direct
de certains commentaires d'internautes
qui s'interroge sur les ovnis les
survols et les phénomènes inexpliqués au
dessus de centrales nucléaires on a par
exemple nicolas paulin sagittarius à et
olivier est celle qui s'interroge
nicolas poulin qui nous dit comment
explique-t-on les phénomènes lumineux
observés près des centrales nucléaires
et plus particulièrement après des
accidents nucléaires
sagittarius à qui nous dit des rapports
des enquêtes après les survols d'ovni de
centrales nucléaires en france en 2014 y
at il des informations et olivier sls
qui nous dit avez vous des informations
sur des survols de centrales nucléaires
françaises par dépend leur a coûté yale
de réponse
la première on a connaissance d'une
enquête qui a été menée par le geipan en
2010 de ce qui avait été observé par
deux gardiens qui l'ont pris pour un
ovni en quelque sorte enquête qui a été
menée qui concluait
la possibilité aux soins d'un avion soit
plus vraisemblablement de drones
sauf qu'à cette époque là je pense qu'on
n'en parlait pas beaucoup des drones il
ya des études qui ont été faites
l'équipe i paco françois louanges à fait
d analyse d'image alors à vide à mort il
ya des ambiguïtés il ya des bons des
lampadaires à proximité mais cela dit
franchement il y avait rien
d'extraordinaire dans ce qui a été
constaté pas du tout de mouvements
extrêmement brusque et c'est bien
ensuite deuxième question le survol on
n'a pas d'information particulière nous
sur ce sujet là sur le sur gold
centrales et autres ce que l'on peut
dire quand même qui ça c'est de
notoriété publique et tous les médias
s'ils sont intéressés à l'époque c'est
qu'en 2013 2014
il ya eu un certain nombre de survols de
zone centrale par des drones
il ya eu des auditions qui ont été
faites à l'assemblée nationale tout ça
n'est pas mystérieux c'est à cacher
c'est de notoriété publique
il ya eu également des incidents sur les
aéroports en grande-bretagne en
allemagne et c'est parce qu'il y avait
des drones
donc vous voyez il faut pas tout
mélanger faut faire la part des choses
on arrive au terme de cet entretien
luchini merci encore pour vos éclairages
vos explications vos précisions sur le
sujet des ovnis et dépend on va
peut-être laisser le mot de la fin à
christian léon toussaint qui nous suit
sur le chat du figaro.fr et qui nous dit
moi les ovnis j'y crois il existe
vraiment prouvé et rapport implacable
hergé a fait un rapport dans les sept
boules de cristal
voilà est-ce que vous avez des choses à
ajouter les cliniques dé des choses
peut-être qu'on n'aurait pas évoqué
ensemble et que vous teniez à dire bah
écoutez je vais je visite dominée par
une pirouette dont l'équipe sigma 2
c'est pas le professeur tournesol
ça pourrait ressembler un peu mais on
est tout à fait sérieux et il me semble
que dans les sept boules de cristal en
tous les cas il ya aussi une similitude
avec la foudre en boule et pas seulement
les jauges unis par contre dans le vol
714 pour sydney là il ya un
extraterrestre autant que je me
souvienne merci encore lydie ni pour vos
éclairages et vous et vos explications
sérieuses je rappelle que vous êtes
ingénieur en construction aéronautique
et vêtements
de l'association aéronautique et
astronautique de france qu'on appelle
3af c'est une des rares sociétés
savantes nationale et vous êtes
également président de la commission
technique
sigma 2 qui vient de publier un rapport
sur les pans je vous invite à revoir ce
replay et à écouter tout ce que lui dit
ni vous a dit et qui est fort
intéressant et ultra sérieux
à très vite sur vicat or alive merci
encore pour vos commentaires merci pour
votre accueil et toutes les questions